hallo und herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen video hier ist laser luca so war
es auf der glow und tod ist auch dem man
erst richtig
los eine beauty messe die hat dieses
jahr gästen stattgefunden deswegen
dachte sich luca muss natürlich auch da
hat sich auch ja seid trotzdem irgendwie
beide eingeladen wo wir beide nichts mit
beauty
ganz komisch jedes mädchen hat sie ein
grünes oder ein pinkes kleid an
erste tag war der samstag war ich schon
ein bisschen ehe auf dem klo habe dann
versucht man aufs messegelände gehen da
ging nicht weil echt viele zuschauer da
waren zugesagt weil es keine ist ja das
anders und übrigens das musst du willst
wir gehen ja blöd ich hab's zu zwei
städten gesorgt hat mir keiner was
gegeben vielleicht bin ich zu unberührt
tablett dachten diese was will die denn
die gehört die sandra schon gesagt hat
sie war halt an dem samstag also dem
ersten tag schon um 11 oder soweit er da
ich kam dann in 15 uhr fünf minuten
bevor wir uns mit ingrid und ich dachte
du schaffst das schon einige sagen
dieses jahr kommt später keiner kommt um
die ecke denken gab sogar teig ist ja
tut bleibt guckt auf jeweils ich spürte
kommst du in der gar nicht so wenn du
vertraust du mich ja und ich sagte kommt
es zu spät sein das hat der
unglücklichste mensch heute werden
gesagt haben dass um 12 uhr ist ein
schlafender worte ich habe nur 12 uhr c
dann hab ich sagen dass mir erst mal in
meine wohnung gezeigt ich kann ich erst
mal nur hier so ein bisschen kann ich
erst mal zeigen ja total tor
sie ist ein schwarzes brett charlotte
geht raus dann kam es heute zu mir weil
ich ihn mal die wohnung jetzt zum ersten
mal so kurz gezeigt weil die wohnung
weil wir keinen fahrstuhl ist jedenfalls
wieder gras ersten gegangen war den
walter sagt ganz liebe grüße bestes
restaurant meiner ansicht nach ja finde
ich auch sehr viele paare auch super
generell könne nicht gute gastgeber aber
wir waren auf jeden fall das essen auch
wdr steht vorbeigegangen halt die geigen
gedacht die wollen presse mit uns
ehrlich sein wir uns einigen wollen aber
den bürgersteig film ja bei dem wie der
bürgersteig erweitert werden soll auch
das komplette scheiß ist doch eine ganz
aus dass die grünen hier aus köln sehen
sollten das zerstört
ich finde wenn ihr abend der straße
zeigte gekürzt was ich ja erst mal gar
nicht mehr durch der erster punkt
schaltet das der kultur
wie inwiefern schadet das der kultur ja
kultur ist ja friede freude eierkuchen
stürmte unterstand macht warum heißt
diese habe drogerie porto eigentlich
kulturbeutel
fragen ergeben auch schon zehn jahre
erklären ich kann auf jeden fall an wir
haben an unserer mit ingrid und haben
dann voll viele von euch auch getroffen
wir waren tatsächlich und das hat mich
sehr gewundert dass du mir gesagt der
ausgebuchte meet greets locker das hat
mir eine mitarbeiterin gesagt dass er
gibt meiner ansicht nach absolut gar
keinen sinn weil wir wieder irgendwie
riesig promo dafür gemacht haben noch
superstar mit ingrid war tatsächlich das
beste das ich je hatte man hatte genug
zeit für jede person die den leuten
wurden die handys vorher abgenommen
damit bilder gemacht werden konnten weil
von euch jetzt also oder haben sie ein
timer da bleibt man kann zu unterhalten
es gab etwas zu trinken und so also es
war echt sehr cool war mein erstes mich
was ich hatte
im ernst hätte er so was noch nie weil
ich mir jemand treffen wollte ja da ganz
gut sagen die moderatorin die hat lugano
gab es zuvor nicht verstanden worauf
freust du dich am meisten
ja
und ich regelung weiter
das verstehen wir jetzt nicht es geht
heute weiter ja das war echt cool
das kam auf seinem zu minimalstem offen
zudem
richtig denn dass die chance auf erfolg
war gestern die leute vor dem seeberger
müssen
also seeberger erstmalig zur erklärung
ist eine marke die machen sowas hier das
habt ihr selbst schon mal im supermarkt
gesehen so müssen studenten wechsel ins
rad und diesem geist es kann teuer eine
packung kostet 56 euro auf jeden fall
habe ich halt an also was ich selber mal
produzieren japanischen aufbauen im
garten wo wachsen müsse nußbaum
auf jeden fall hatten wir ja dieses
mädchen geriet und dann kam dieser zwei
jungs von seeberger an aus ulm sind die
glaube ich das unternehmen ja noch ein
bisschen auch so sieht deutsch
gesprochen und dann hat er eine freude
macht seeberger wir machen müsste cashew
walnuss ich so früh noch einmal kommen
die wieder fünf tüten in die hand
gedrückt alles voll mit müssen hier
wurde eben nichts geschenkt ich habe mir
alles selber aus kartons rost
wir haben beim elektrohändler pamela
gebraucht ich war total nervös und
wollte mal sehen wir doch mal ein pick
mit der abend da hat mich erst nicht
getraut einmal habe ich sie gesehen bei
den video der ist von praia da dachte
ich schon support ist echt mini bei
dieser kleider noch mal ein steak nicht
so groß wie du ja oder noch klein also
ist einzig noch noch ein tick größer
schau dort geht raus auf jeden fall weil
wir dieses instagram headquarter
reingehen ja irgendwie so ein container
einfach und natürlich gab es gegenüber
zu essen was irgendwie ab 14 euro gab es
nicht mehr meerwasser irgendwie leer
aber wir wollen auf jeden fall dann dort
und wollte nach rein gehen oder mal die
sonne geht gerade ich kann nicht sehen
warum david platt getreten so pamela
reifen wird so einen kleinen lauf der
hoch und runter vom release logo und
dreht er immer wieder gedreht das war
rein gegangen sondern auch foto mit
pamela anderson ich brauche dich
zukommen beginn hin zu werke gegangen
und ich habe ja erst ich habe erst auf
englisch mit der geredet echt nichts mit
hey schießt jbg stanley heidel und das
ist mir selber aufzeigen die blöd dies
ihr deutsch damit ist der größte fan
gewesen hier bild übrigens von seinem
dauernden pamela gabelstapler auch noch
getroffen es ist schön zum bild vom
sommer gemacht oder rot ich muss sagen
ich hab echt
außer twenty four tim k und vielleicht
noch so fünf habe kann ich fünf leute da
und wünschen da an wird man hier wieder
schnell wie ich diese ganzen branche ist
wie viele leute da mittlerweile meet and
greet amiga diese leute stand oder
weniger aber wie viele leute
mittlerweile in fenstern oder generell
über tik tok sich eine reichweite
aufbauen deshalb total weil ich hatte
dann auch ein foto gemacht mit seinem
edel die wahl ob ich 17 oder so locker
ließ sie glaube ich und dann war hier
aber auch plötzlich mit in diesem
creator den bei instagram natürlich
außenterrasse machst du auch so was
dabei naja ich habe jetzt in den letzten
30 tagen hab ich jetzt in die 40.000
neue follower auf instagram gemacht und
soll ich denke
das hat man gar nicht mehr so richtig
auf dem schirm nachdem die eine person
die ihr handy nicht zurück haben wollte
so mir gerne eine person also ein wenig
auskennt will hat man mich mit den
worten du weißt du die nächsten die sind
sogar ich super viel spaß aber seine
kannst du kurz drüber gehe nicht warum
ich wollte nur ein foto von der box
das war die globe ja wir hatten zwar
liegen blaue waren trotzdem da ja hat
mir so viel spaß haben wie gesagt panel
antwort du bist mit nackten füßen auf
einem teppich ja
dann kann ich ja gleich wieder modischen
hat unseren podcast deggendorf machst du
schon wie so professor youtube blogger
im bisherigen dieses sehe ich hier sind
auf jeden fall wir bei hashtag in flames
aber so hört euch gern die neue folge
dick und doof an da geht es um
luca geht's dort beraten
was
gegenwärtig in das rad vorgestellt dabei
klärt uns vor samsung herkommt ich
erkläre veganen ernährungsweise herzlich
gern nochmal spotify wir hören uns
laurent hier wieder auf der neuen folge
wenn hier das passiert ich wünsche sage
mal an der stelle tobias dass sein
kumpel tobias aber ich glaube ihr seid
nicht die gleiche person ich bin hier
mit seiner schwester oder von schwester
okay naja wird schön hat in essen
das ist eine mutter gibt die kinos an
die sind genauso wie sie haben
ich hoffe nach st
[Musik]